[Applause]
hey look at me
happy freaky friday i hope you had a
glorious week i did i got a wart removed
[Laughter]
not intentionally
i got drunk last night and passed out in
the kitchen with my hand and a panini
maker
burnt that sucker right off
i also recently had a mole removed you
know when chris wallace went to cnn
unnecessary i don't even know him who
cares but i had that wart forever
so i figured i'd name it brian kilmeade
it reminded me of him because it was
small unsightly and annoying
but speaking of kill mead you ever heard
of the word thirsty as it's used in
current slang it's not like wanting a
beer it's what the kids say to express
an obvious desire for attention so you
do stuff to get noticed it's like people
who post shirtless photos of themselves
or people who fake an arrest
yeah
or people who wear repulsive jackets
egg him on
but you know who's really thirsty
this weepy fella
i keep waiting for him to pull out a
doll to show where trump touched him
that's disgusting then there's this lady
man is shh is she cold
in dc when they deliver donor organs to
the hospital they place them under her
armpit
that's cold
and of course there's the dams who are
super thirsty i bet they ate worms to
impress people in grade school and to
fight climate change
hence that prime time jan 6 hearing last
night did you watch it
me either i watched a celebrity edition
of chopped
i saw snooki lose a nose ring in her
bulia bays
but no you have a life unlike them so
here's a recap of the hearing
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
true while you were making dinner
playing with your kids
or playing with your dinner and making
kids
these thirsty bozos are trying to
attract attention to their lost cause
you know it's like those phone calls i
get from ducey to go on nature hikes
dude i know what that's
about count me in
but boy did the hearings backfire for
their party and for joe how badly well
like people turning away when lance
armstrong strips they took their eyes
off the ball
while they focused all their limited iqs
on destroying trump the current
president is now less popular than
chlamydia
but despite all the bad things they say
about trump he was more popular after
january 6th than biden is now
that's amazing which could explain the
covet diagnosis not saying it's a ploy
but it came at the right time
and by the right time
i mean less than 24 hours after his
cancer announcement
[Applause]
i won't be surprised tomorrow if he
tells us he has monkey pox
and blames it on a pair of underwear he
borrowed from hunter
man
because the timing is more suspicious
than a google ad for weight loss that
pops up right after i click on a clip of
brian stelter
it's weird
uncanny and so realizing that in
november they're going to get their
asses whipped like egg whites in a
meringue
they announced more hearings more
hearings for september it's the sequel
no one asked for
like major league three back to the
miners
but you don't see us bringing scott
bakula up on charges
it's an actor
it's the first show in the history of
american tv that jumped the shark
halfway through the pilot episode so
what are they going to talk about then
last night get this they found out
melania didn't know about january 6 as
it was happening you know what were they
expecting her to admit that she's the
one who gave ray epps a ride to the riot
she's not she's not obsessively
scrolling through twitter while sniffing
her fingers which is exactly what the
press does now
and do you remember the trump grabs the
wheel bombshell
now it's been downgraded to a heated
discussion
what are they going to downgrade it to
next a terse game of freeze tag
so they're coming back in september when
i'll be distracted by those impressive
back to school savings
and i don't even go to school
but i get it elections are coming up and
their only hope is a distraction from
reality another show trial that you're
paying for while americans get mugged at
the gas pump the supermarket and pretty
much everywhere else i'd suggest running
but even people running for governor get
attacked the dems aren't even hiding
their political thirstiness and the
networks abide because when democrats
fart they'll sniff it
[Laughter]
and this is one big collective fart
if it was any more methane china would
use it in a power plant
you'd think the networks would be pissed
for being played and contemplate the
opportunity costs as these a-holes
prattle on we have inflation war and
crime raging
no wonder people have less faith in the
media than snake charmers but they don't
care over the years the media developed
stockholm syndrome and fell in love with
their captors which is the democrat
party
but what's good for the goose is good
for the gander
you know that gander must really hate
the goose
it's like
stop it goose
i'll be next
what did the gander ever do i could do
this for hours
but once the republicans take over
november it's going to be hunter joe
hearings nonstop and it's going to be
like the bachelor lost 24 and those
faces of death dvds rolled into one
yes
give me some rest
think of the drinking games
every time you hear big guy you drink
every time hunter faces the camera nude
you really drink
hell imagine if you drink every time
hunter lights his crack pipe
your liver would have more holes in it
than his defense
so by all means dems and media keep
pushing the hearings it's working
against you you reveal your bias and
your ambivalence toward the real
concerns americans have and it's not
going to end well for you
hell you may end up working for cnn
[Applause]
she crunches more numbers than my cousin
who eats calculators
r.i.p seth host of the evening edited on
fox business liz mcdonnell
he's like salmon he goes against the
current and is sometimes held by bears
editor-in-chief of outspoken and
contributing editor of the spectator
chadwick moore
grandmothers love him because his jacket
matches their wallpaper walks across
america host jimmy fella
and finally her points are as sharp as
her elbows fox news contributor cat tim
[Music]
so uh jimmy because you wore that
disgusting jacket
do you want to do you want to see a
picture of what they did but my wart
after it got removed oh goodness show it
to me
oh my god
it was deep but it's actually pretty
tiny like the host of this show
oh yeah
you sent it to me that morning
i mean that is disgusting though
it's amazing that that's on my finger
this finger anyway i can't show it to
the audience right
where'd i get the wart oh man
[Laughter]
[Music]
a little place called paradise island
[Laughter]
so
jimmy um
you're acquainted with thirstiness have
you seen a more desperate ploy and a
more and a more obvious ploy than this
oh the january 6th yeah yeah no this is
hilarious the only part last night i
enjoyed was when they were showing
people get arrested because at least we
saw real handcuffs for the first time
this week
although we're all going to feel dumb
when we find out aoc really did get
handcuffed by the invisible guy biden's
been shaking hands with
but let me make let me make a very
serious point it can't move the needle
politically and the reason being it's
not it's not partisan to say this is to
objective observers if calling an
election stolen deserves jail time every
democrat from 2016 is doing life right
now you know what i'm saying yeah so
they're on tv every night telling you
that 20 20 people deserve uh prison
right the 2016 people deserve pulitzer's
how about
you know you know what i mean
and that's why nobody's watching you
know um
the funny thing is
politicians think we're so stupid that
in 2024 if and probably the rep will the
republicans win they're going to say
that that's stolen of course they're
going to pretend like
nothing they said said now during jan 6
matters liz do you think the public sees
how biased these hearings are yeah the
polls are showing that yeah i think
people are done i mean people know the
capital riots were exquirable should
never happen again but what are they
going to do get a netflix streaming deal
and go into like 2024 with it i mean
they what they what i see dc it's like
they're standing in the middle of the
room with a paper bag in their head
right in their own they're in their own
world i mean for example nancy pelosi
her office says her spouse does the
stock trades right yeah yes she lives in
a community property state she owns half
the stocks so you know so it's such a
you know what i mean so this this the in
their bubble kind of world and the rest
of the country is saying what are you
doing yeah right let's let's move on it
just sucks that that they can actually
get the networks to do it like we're
gonna do it in prime time yeah i mean
what was on thursday kat you know what's
on thursday night no i've been
re-watching summer house oh okay
i don't know what that is
i feel bad for you oh well screw you cat
chad wick
uh scott adams you know him creator of
gilbert made this great point he
believes the
insurrection hoax has replaced the
russian collusion hoax it's almost the
same mapping of it yeah it's where they
it's like they keep doing these these
hearings over and over again but all
they're doing is recycling the the their
mind reading the things that they can't
see but they think is going on in
donald's head and it's so much less
compelling than russiagate was the
coverage i was i met a j6 true believer
the other day and i was so shocked
because he was one of these like
clintonian liberals who agreed with me
on most things like the woke stuff and
blah blah as soon as j6 came up he was
like we're not talking about that
he was so upset and it was an attacker
and i was like wow you really believe
he's glued to the tv right he can't wait
for the next episode yes it was
astounding to meet this person i didn't
know they existed well this is the point
greg's making though is it's become an
emotional thing for them right and they
don't hear themselves but we keep
changing the claim of the committee it
started with he incited this riot and he
should go to jail for this yes now we're
being told it's melania's fault
and then like they were closing last
night with well we're just here to make
sure it doesn't happen again right one
nice thing under biden is it can't
happen again because there's no way that
many people can afford the gas money to
get to dc
so we're fine
the walls are closing in on melania
that's what they say
the walls are closing in kat you've got
to be as angry as i am every time you
consider that we're paying for this oh
yeah i know yeah i am because well how
many times you know can you say like it
was bad
i wasn't there
you know like it was bad and even the
stuff that's new that comes out isn't
really new it's kind of stuff we are
it's details about stuff that we already
did know which i think actually the only
thing that could have been helpful for
anyone would be
what melania said because i think that'd
be very helpful for all the people that
get interviewed or interrogated on the
first 48 yeah yeah they're always like
uh who killed the person they're like i
did it
you weren't there you don't i don't know
what you're talking about so if you're a
murderer yeah it is
it's true but it's like
when you look at so what's happening is
90 of whoever was there was just
wandering around it was like a tour
group gone amok
and then and i know people that
say that they were let in and no you
don't hear anything about that dude
there were people that were there let in
okay walking around in chewbacca bikinis
[Laughter]
yo they are still in jail right now
dude are you sure that's a chewbacca
bikini or they're just her suit it's
it's weird because it reminds me of that
hat the water buffalo hat from the
flintstones you know what i mean
for those of you under 45 the
flintstones were a cartoon
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else